yolande c'est squeeze et aujourd'hui
pour la première fois où la première
fois depuis très longtemps on est sur un
jeu de voiture mais le scar game
pourquoi ma voiture est déjà dans cet
état qui a fait ça bon plus précisément
on n'est pas sur le vrai jeu puisque le
jeu et est actuellement en accès
anticipé voilà là c'est une sorte de
version pour ceux qui ont précommandé le
jeu une sorte de cour de récréation pour
voiture un une voiture et demi une
voiture et demi non c'est l'envol et
c'est l'envol c'est l'envol
oui et maintenant le décès
tu attends ça sont plus à rien coin de
conserve mais bon il a quand même le
petit bouton magique a agi comme ça quel
pilote pouvait baisser le cours de
récréation sont décodés c'est juste un
truc qui nous envoie un peu partout ça
va j'ai compris des tonneaux attendez je
crois que je peux tirer attendez
attendez attendez bousculade épisode qui
dit s'amuser à me rentrer dedans on le
prend en chasse à temps mais c'est quoi
c'est bien voulu me faire du mal
le au joli os c'est quoi cette araignée
géante est ce qu'on veut la tuer alric
qui sera dans un rpg
non c'est un jeu de voiture lui qu'est
ce qu'on pourrait la tuer j'ai dit oh oh
oh [ __ ] mais en fait ces bouchons
énormes
laisse moi on a les ailes par contre
elle peut nous aux médias un pilote
brossard - pilote c'est plus une sorte
de robot et heureusement pour lui
d'ailleurs les vachement flat quand même
c'est un origami en fait ce pilote voilà
alain ok d'accord à temps mais attend le
truc est tellement compacte et que c'est
un vélo quoi attend déjà zappé ce qui se
passe cela s'appelait ce qui se passe là
ça me plaît beaucoup
on s'envole dans les lices alors ça
c'est genre de déception que je déteste
avoir à les suppléer pas sortir un mot
sionnel s'il vous plaît
oh non pepy sur le shield voilà c'est
pas répartie encore en ce moment il est
vrai que j'ai un gros problème avec les
réparties voilà je ne sais plus justifié
les choses ah oui allez cette fois
souple et on y va c'est bon cette fois
et c'est pas possible
mais même sur un jeu où c'était pas
possible d'être nul on est nul c'est
incroyable ça devrait être dans le livre
des records à un moment je sais pas
faire quelque chose sur un concours pour
les nuls
ok demi tour sachez faire alors je ne
sais même pas faire demi tour puis là on
est pas mal on est pas mal on est dedans
on est de bons sa rage quit à wattrelos
que je peux aller on en attendait je
crois que ma boule boucher l'entrée mais
nommés plus tard yabuki atterri là où il
faut pas dans les cheveux la poule c
rassurez moi
mais comment je fais pour être nul sur
un jeu comme ça dégage voilà c'est bon
c'est mon vide font profiter pour
profiter non ça donne un peu la gerbe
mais y'a un petit style et je me bloque
quoi première au monde à se bloquer non
mais ça va pas là voilà c'est bon il m'a
fait apparaître un autre endroit très
bien au sein parcours comme c'est mignon
regard des audiences des émissions
chinoises là où les chants tombe
lamentablement mais là on est voiture et
on tombe lamentablement quand même sur
des six à mon gars arrêtez s'il vous
plaît or il ya un petit tabac batmobile
maintenant il ya un petit air batmobile
ah oui y'a quoi au bout et soi-même
petite récompense au moins vous non on
pourra juste dire à nos amis qu'on a
réussi et ne croiront pas donc ils se
moqueront de nous que n'aura plus d'amis
puis on ira se coucher en position
foetale c'est ça la suite un alléchant
drift devant les copines dans l'espoir
d'endiguer une bon j'arrive pas très
bien je n'aurai pas de copine c'est
parti à on a un ami qui s'amusent là on
va le canon à eau sur l'arrêt des eaux
non tu nous a déçus ah ok donc si tu as
tout en haut tu marques 7 points est ce
qu'on vise le 6.2 4 points le 1 point
zack and on ne passe entre tous les
panneaux mais est ce qu'un jour je vais
faire un truc style et dans cette vidéo
oh [ __ ] mais c'est un vrai missile qui
par quoi attendait j'aimerais juste voir
d'où part ce missile
bon déjà il part du capot mais il est
resté dans le capot est ce que je n'ai
plus de voiture mais parce qu'ils visent
vers moi ah mais c'est pas mal c'est une
sorte de jet pack finalement au crt
blanc s'avère très violent je sais pas
s'il ya un but ou si le but est
simplement de se faire défoncer pas un
truc qui tourne attendait non il ya pile
la place pour la voiture passe hop ça
c'est des préfabriqués la doyenne des
gens qui apprennent les mathématiques et
l'école a fait construire ces trucs là
autour pour qu'ils apprennent justement
bien les mathématiques à l'ajout d'une
petite sécurité quand même [ __ ] mais
c'est sans déconner on dire des trucs
qu'on utilisait la piscine pour pas se
noyer et quoi les marchés en mousse mais
tu sais que ça ça mur d'escaladé pour
voiture c'est vrai que c'est carrément
ça dit quoi aïe
qu'est ce que ça fait c'est que ça une
barrière c'est un saut de haies saut de
haies version voiture ça plaît beaucoup
noah d'accord faut casser c'est le plus
haut possible entente looping parce
qu'on va y arriver
je prends le foot à la voiture mais non
mais oui mais elle tombe hélas pas mal
une sorte de looping mais sans toucher
le looping la voiture survie au nom je
voulais vous montrer l aime pas l aime
pas être en position de faiblesse elle
se sent humilié ça ça me plaît
énormément au roulement à canon [ __ ]
il fait pas les choses à moitié
hopla très bien bah oui on pouvait pas
atterrir dans la mousse mignonne nom
d'un à cette destruction c'est
incroyable oh mon dieu un collègue est
mort attends je vais décoincer voilà up
penser que c'est l'arrivée
oui il renaît de ses de ses cendres de
ce morceau de métal amateurs et cette
voiture est décédé mais il ne reste plus
rien monsieur feuille a4 ou êtes-vous
monsieur à 4 le seul moyen de retrouver
monsieur à 4 et de devenir une feuille
a4 d'un tintin
oh non aussi il est plus à 4 que jamais
oui c'est incroyable
il est littéralement encastré dans la
voiture il ne fait plus qu'un en
parfaite harmonie avec leurs jeunes avec
le bolide 8 9 10 quand la dernière au
moins la voiture n'est pas cassé voilà
au nom en plus ça j'aurais dû me taire
bon on a quand même eu la médaille de
bronze au saut d'eau et inversement
voiture je suis convaincu qu'on va y
arriver
allez allez oui oui oui non oui en route
et le redressement et c'est
l'atterrissage dans de la mousse va
sauter alors là alors la hausse et fait
un public une fanbase d'au moins trois
personnes pensaient qu'il ya un monsieur
à quatre dans le coffre
on n'en est rien la déception il ya rien
d'un coffre alors par contre c'est
l'extérieur de la voiture est plutôt
attirant l'intérieur c'est tout autre
chose quoi tu ne peux pas emmener une
fille quelque part dans cette voiture
c'est pas possible
mais déjà elle n'a pas de siège pour
commencer elle soit en tailleur sur une
plaque de métal bon c'est pas mal il ya
des heurts sont atteints c'est loin de
le savoir
c'était quoi ça se compte en centimètres
déjà je pense oh mon dieu vous voyez ça
c'est une véritable cité de jeunes qui
apprennent les mathématiques arrêté
apprenez les sciences et vie voilà aux
apparences tech
non on s'est arrêté sur la ligne comme
d'un film d'action avant le vide allez
caroline voile ap carolina voiture non
mais que c'est que ça sonne et
connaissent et des paniers voilà comme
mia supermarchés pour faire ses courses
annoncé décaisser des sceaux pour moi si
les gens aiment faire leurs courses dans
les caisses et les sauges urbaine
inconvénients 1 je suis prêt ok le
premier non mais sérieusement non voilée
on joue entre copines moi c'est caroline
ou là sylvie tu te calmes mais on est en
5e et notre ami ou battus attention il
ya pleins d'à 4 en fait nan mais non
mais attends les cieux tranquille à tort
ou à défaut on va le défendre comme le
pauvre il est où ils ont rackettés ils
ont dépouillé puis lors abandonné 3 les
lâche moi je t'aimais bien vraiment
pourquoi toujours faire des roues comme
ça si vous envoyez un message à
quiconque mais pour des doux carlo son
côté carlos
vous devez me parler carlos wayne fowkes
carlos web on voit les gens c'est bien
la fin de cette vidéo sur nes et game
l'espace vous aura plu c'est le cas
n'hésitez pas à me les deux ça fera
vraiment plaisir
j'ai envie de faire une vidéo un peu
différente de d'habitude qui n'était pas
sur un jeu what the fuck ou un jeu
d'horreur ou un jeu à plusieurs voilà je
trouvais ça sympa de pour une fois faire
un jeu de voiture sachant que j'en ai
jamais fait surtout que celui-là il est
vraiment sympa je pense que les consoles
il ya plusieurs rendront plutôt bien et
comme j'ai dit y aura des morceaux de
métal partout n'hésitez pas à me joindre
un commentaire si ça vous plaît que des
fois on découvre un jeu ensemble qui
soit différent qu'ils soient pas
suffisamment moins de 5 ou d'horreur on
se retrouve très vite dans une nouvelle
vidéo tient tout le monde pis bas depuis
parfait le double
[Musique]